hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to forgotten this is a game
that I found on gamejolt that looked
pretty interesting from what I saw this
is yours it represents every memory
you've ever had hold onto it for what is
a person stand without his memories
every single individual is a product of
their past okay you picked up the
bracelet and put out on your wrist for
safe giving if you wanna pick sakai
forget that up pressing key will tell
you more about what you're looking at
middle click toggle is your lighter
shift allows you to sprint because this
game is Owen complete you should expect
a lot of placeholder graphics and bugs
consider yourself warned if you are
interested in aiding the development
there seeking a 3d artist and sound
composer so here we go open door and
follow the light seriously if you get
lost look around until you see things
light up ok you got it buddy
wait a minute this door goes nowhere
what oh oh okay oh hello I seem to have
been dropped into a foggy forest and I
said follow the light but I don't
particularly see any light here um ok
it's darker over there and it's brighter
over here I'm guessing that means I need
to follow this way what does that sound
you guys hear that
or am I just going crazy no I asked you
if you hear something what the hell is
that
is that oh hello the house with some
strange noises going into I like the
graphics very nice very nice hello why
is it so far ghee in here why would I be
foggy in here oh no at least there's
some color wait a minute what though
the fog is fading out and the colors are
fading in that's so cool kinda I think
yes that is cool ok that's just a clock
there's actually pretty well done I'm
pretty impressed where something is so
early in development what's in here now
there's some sailors that I could pick
up Samantha's diary yeah you can see a
lot of page has been torn out are are
illegible I asked my mommy to bring my
diary
when she went to the with empty the
buckets so now I can write it in the
past up to pass the time maybe now it
won't be so boring in here if I could
talk properly clack sorry I guess it
didn't warm up enough before I started
this recording I'm gonna try better wait
a minute
I'm excuse me excuse me who be banging
who be banging
should I go towards that or what delay
okay
I'm so sorry I had to do it please take
her to the hospital for help
oh but open that door
something's evil behind that door okay
all right then Oh what is this day don't
forget to pick a milk and extra snacks
for Samantha and Nikki you stay still I
can actually open the fridge that's
actually quite impressive for something
this small
do not be fooled and think that a man's
memories will not free themselves from
his mind I just read that instead I like
how when I press Sarita it gets smaller
texts than what I had before
oh thank you baby do ones that baby do
huh
guessing that I gotta open the door get
on the floor everybody do the done the
door's locked
good maybe that's for the best what the
hell happened in here
why is everything boarded up in this
room is where the baby was supposed to
be dude what's with the buckets who's
with the bear you can see on the teddy
bears neck it's dead Nikki's favorite is
this same feels peculiar and off you can
feel something strong coming for like a
snake trying to get into your skull what
does that mean I'm slightly disturbed
crib looks completely unused various
papers most very illegible
well I asked mommy when we could come
back out and live with the rest of the
house but she keeps telling me not until
the Batman goes away who's the bad man
why won't he leave us alone today she
boarded up the windows in the door she's
getting really scared and so am i I've
been forever it's been forever since
I've seen daddy I swear I saw him
outside the window last night but it was
so dark
I wonder if the bad man got him I really
miss him
out of food and mommy has to go all the
way to the grocery store to buy
something she told me not to leave the
room just in case but I found the key to
all the house downstairs under weight
doors house doors under pillow I
couldn't stop crying after seeing all
the old photos of me daddy and mommy we
were so much happier before we had Nicky
he brought home a really fancy necklace
but she said it was for my sister she
talks like about her like she's real and
sometimes it really worries me what if
she is real and I just can't see her
daddy told me that mommy needs help
though
last night daddy knocked on the window
and said he was going to get me and take
me where it's safe
I've never been happier well now there's
another one of those things huh
okay so under the pillow under the this
pillow or under under this pillow under
one of these pillows it said under a
pillow so I'm gonna just ah wait no I
see it
yeah house key let's open the door come
on bring it on hello okay Emma light
well I oh no no no Lilly Lilly Lilly
sister stink
Oh everything has changed why is this
the locked no kidding it's locked
oh oh oh oh no oh no oh no oh no this
reminds me of the sequence from Max
Payne it is dreamed oh no no no no can't
make me oh I'm gonna do there's no baby
in the head but it feels like it wants
you it needs you what do I do
I am baby
Susan shut up no baby I don't know what
to do I do about babies let alone creepy
disturbing the otic babies ooh
what do I do he's ready to do what am I
supposed to go revise what to do about
that baby was fare something I don't
know what to do but what do we do wait
was it no nothing wait what okay sir
back up y'all I'm sorry I'm a horrible
horrible uncle I think I told you all
about the story about me and my nephew
he stole my Easter candy so I made him
cry
true story hospital bed smells like
urine and feels out of place no joke
what do I do
what am I supposed to do I don't know
what to do maybe there was something
under the crib was it
I don't think so what am I about to do
it needs me what does that mean I'm not
being stupid am I we do dude stop crying
what am I gonna do I jump into the crib
I'm sorry I'm sorry baby oh goodness
what do I do
how would I do I don't know I don't know
what I do I need I need to not be there
I guess what do we do do we do oh I'm
hungry I'm hungry I'm hungry that wasn't
there before was that there before well
there's a key here oh okay
what was that there okay let's go in
here okay I got a bad feeling about this
one
um all right then
okay okay okay okay
oh no oh no I get your formula baby baby
I get your man what was that
who is all that okay okay baby you're
doing good
what is that okay lock now probably for
the best whatever was going on in that
room I don't want to relive where's my
teddy mommy I can't sleep I'm afraid the
bad man will give me okay okay am i
Cameron
better shut up lady I don't want to know
anything I don't know okay hmm shut up I
can't pick up the teddy bear gentle
warmth or the candle ooh I don't know
where the crying is coming from I know I
get the teddy bear oh shut up lady I'm
out here I'm out here
oh wow I will kill the baby
oh all of you I finish the demo you mean
that's it was easy to read patient
arrived young female pregnant starting
labor patient having a hard time and
we're making progress patient even
Giuliana baby still didn't make it
stell birthday she won't listen need to
admit her to psychiatric psychiatry okay
okay oh look a giant hole with would you
shut up lady our finish this demo I'm
done with your ball I'm done with all
your ball
okay I'm gonna throw myself in hole now
uh oh uh all right then Wow
I guess that's it then I can't move hey
how's the end of the demo I guess that's
it then I guess I'm done I guess it's
all over oh wait a minute what's going
on
Oh what is this what is this you grab
the pendant and class stand at the end F
of it around your bracelet - hold on - I
can't read this I'm having a tough time
reading anything in here okay so it gets
darker over there
try to follow the light again lights
that way it's almost blinding so what's
over here wait a minute oh I see the
lights only at the thing it's that every
stand of the demo so I'm gonna assume
that there wasn't anything really more
to this
maybe yeah this is only guiding me to
the pendant thing but maybe there's a
path here I think I see kind of like a
nope
whoa what is this resist what are this
what are this what are this what are
this hmm what are these what do we have
here maybe this isn't the end of the
demo I seem to still be playing despite
the fact that the demo said it ended yep
I'm still playing I'm still uh still
doing the thing doing that thing what am
i doing
hello oh hi feel the power and the beat
of your butt yeah unbe oh it's dark in
here
oh this is lovely oh I shouldn't be
wandering into this I I still don't know
if there's anything actually I still
don't know if there's anything actually
to this but I seem to have found the
creepiest part of the entire house which
is good for me this is thick this is the
end of this level so far oh oh
ah hang on let me just oh I think that
might be it ah but it was going I was
really excited to play this this is a
really well done game
it's definitely got the atmosphere which
is something that I often will preach
about very much so in in the games that
I play and I always talk about but you
know I'm just a humble game reviewer I
can only report what I feel and what I
feel is that this game was thoroughly
creepy ok that's the end of it there's
really nothing else here feel free to
explore this upcoming level but there's
not anything else you can do here if you
got here by accident want to play a
level that works go see the building
next door
building a story oh really oh really the
building next door I have a feeling that
the building next door is actually just
the building that I first went into but
I don't think I'll be able to find it
because there's no longer any light out
here it's thoroughly dark and I can't
see a damn thing
okay I think that is officially the end
of the level I think I am hey wait a
minute honey does this meat taste weird
to you that's a strange question to ask
hahaha alright I'm just going around the
edges of the building I guess okay
that's it then I think I'm all done here
so there's got a lot of potential you
know check the link in the description
below for the link to the gameplay for
yourself I mean this really does have a
lot of potential the atmosphere was
fantastic throughout it I mean nothing
actually ever jumped out at me but there
was a few times when I thought for sure
something was gonna get me so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
Oh kind of freaky deaky
oh my holy crap that all funny man
got you yeah you're funny man
mo ah what did I know